[MUSIC]
Honorable leadership is
about living up to duty.
When we're given a promotion and put into
a position of greater formal leadership
responsibility, that that is often
because we've done well at something and
our potential has been
positively evaluated.
So if you have a set of different people,
and
some of them are seen as having
greater potential than others,
perhaps they've been more accomplished
than others, then you would expect
them to be put into a position of
responsibility and leadership.
But if you think about it, that causes
all of us to see that promotion
as a reward, not as a duty.
Compare that to a world
where we see a promotion or
other kind of granting of leadership
responsibility as a very solemn
duty that we have been
asked to live up to.
When we face leadership responsibilities,
we're asked to do things
that are difficult.
We're asked to resolve tensions
that will require trade offs.
That will require that
we make tough decisions.
And whenever we do that we
are being challenged to live up
to the duty of our office.
There are exceptional leaders
who perhaps didn't go and
take 100% market share or add a billion
dollars of revenue but day in and
day out we're willing to confront and
deal with the most difficult situations.
And I know right now you
can think of such leaders,
I challenge you to be such a leader.
>> No leader is without opportunity
to grow, so where do you want to go?
Explore Stanford's upcoming programs.
[MUSIC]